Speaker 1: All right, my friends, so I said
yesterday we would be talking about this today,
so let's just jump right into it, because
it's a big topic and and a scary one, quite
frankly.
The question is, does it appear as though
we are barreling towards a second violent
insurrection sometime in the month of August?
Now, let's discuss that.
First of all, why are we even talking about
August?
We're talking about August because The Washington
Post and The New York Times and The National
Review, a conservative leading outlet, have
published articles over the last couple of
weeks outlining to different degrees Donald
Trump's belief or hope that he will be reinstated
as president of the United States sometime
in August of this year, meaning in just a
couple of months.
Now, as you know and as I know, that is impossible.
You and I know that reinstatement is not a
process that is part of the American system
of government.
There is a president, there is a vice president.
If for some reason the president is no longer
president, the vice president becomes the
president.
There is a line of succession.
None of it includes we go back to the previous
guy who lost an election.
It doesn't work that way.
The next presidential election is November
of twenty twenty four.
Whoever wins will be inaugurated in January
of twenty twenty five.
But that doesn't matter to Donald Trump.
And apparently it doesn't matter to millions
of his followers around the country who are
increasingly convinced, increasingly waiting
for their fearless leader to be, quote, reinstated
by the time that summer is over.
There was a really good post on our sub Reddit
that for some reason was since deleted by
the person who posted it.
And it asked potential August insurrection,
is it being overlooked?
And the sub Reddit user pointed out they've
been hearing from family in rural Missouri.
They've been hearing from family in rural
Wisconsin, and many of them are, quote, stocking
up on ammunition and firearms for what is
may be coming in August.
They talk about Trump supposed generals that
he has on his side and their expectation that
there is going to be an attempt to take Joe
Biden out of the White House and put Trump
in sometime during August.
And the Post pointed out something that's
pretty astute, which is that the public facing
media story has been, oh, Mike Flynn talking
about there should be a coup and Donald Trump
continuing to say the election was stolen
and we must do these audits and Trump saying
I will be president again sooner than you
think.
But to people thinking about that below the
surface, there is an incredibly irrational
group of people who believe that that is a
code directed to them, that they should be
ready to take up arms against the government.
And sadly, in practice, it may be functioning
as such a code.
Whether that's what Donald Trump intends or
not, it doesn't even matter in practice.
It very well may function as a code.
In that sense.
Our viewer wrote that many of the people that
he's talking about aren't hugely visible online,
but they are quietly stocking up ammunition,
acquiring firearms and preparing to do the
worst if the time should come.
They point out that the rhetoric they are
seeing on signage in rural Missouri, in rural
Wisconsin, has gotten crazier, you know, about
dead Democrats being the only good ones and
other violent messages.
So the question is whether the possibility
of serious violence in August is being overlooked.
I believe it's important not to be hyperbolic.
I still think the most likely situation is
when Trump doesn't become president in August,
not much violence will happen.
Certainly no big organized violent event and
they'll go and focus on November or the next
January or whatever the case may be.
That's what I think is the most likely outcome.
And they'll put in place some new arbitrary
timeline to look forward to.
But there is precedent for these violent riots.
And the precedent was five months ago when
on January 6th, Trump riots took place in
Washington, DC.
And we are still going through what are now,
I think, four hundred and fifty different
court cases as a result.
So what we can hope is that these folks that
our viewer is seeing in Missouri and in Wisconsin
and elsewhere, no one are on the radar of
law enforcement.
If you come across someone you believe is
planning to do violence, notify local law
enforcement, notify the FBI, the FBI is taking
this seriously.
And number two, for the ones that are determined
to do violence, hopefully it just won't be
convenient for them to get themselves to Washington,
D.C.
It's horrible to have to count on that.
But to some degree, I think it will be a factor
that dissuade some of them as well.
So I share the concern with you at many times
in history, even talking about is it.
Possible that the former president, who has
continued to claim he actually won, will lead
a riot in the middle of another president's
term in order to try to oust that president
in many times in American history, it would
be crazy to even bring this up, sadly, right
now.
This has changed irreversibly because of what
happened in January.
We now have to take this possibility seriously,
and it is a real possibility that they may
do more of it.
And so we're going to continue following it.
We are continuing to see what is the totality
of what we're seeing.
We're seeing what Donald Trump is saying.
Of course, we are starting to see an escalation
in the violent rhetoric from simply Republican
voters.
We are starting to see both online and offline
rhetoric become more radical.
We are hearing from people coded language
like we're going to get the White House back
sooner than you think when it's like, well,
you could get it back in November of twenty,
twenty four.
That's the soonest.
But they're they're going beyond that and
the way that they're hinting and fainting.
So that's FBI and T so unfortunately I share
this concern.
I hope that there is no violence in August,
but I worry that something is building here.
And if so, I do hope law enforcement
is
aware
of it.